do I think all drivers are qualified
some of these drivers really are crazy I
don't understand how these people get
hired hi I'm Pete and today I'm gonna be
sharing with you my ride share horror
story the entire time I can see him
coming I'm thinking just counsel this
guy he's gonna go you're I get into the
car it is a older man and immediately he
just starts telling me how beautiful I
am how I look like I have my together he
asked me where I was going keeps asking
me do I have a boyfriend I say yes cuz I
want him to stop talking to me and it
doesn't stop him enough so your
boyfriend on what you have friends and I
was like no he's crazy he kills people
and he proceeds to tell me like oh yeah
I know why he's killing people because I
know you got some good yep took a hard
left I can tell by the way you sitting
you got that good good and I was like
did not know that vagina had a posture
hey can we change the topic Hills like
oh I'm sorry I didn't mean to offend you
or anything and then he starts going on
to all this I have a four-bedroom house
in Crenshaw and like don't nobody live
with me so if your boyfriend ever like
stuff like I'm here and I'm just like
trying to be nice because I don't want
to like be murdered or raped I texted
one of my guy friend he called me and I
talked to him the rest of the way I was
actually on my way to work as soon as I
get out I reported this man that's like
great a textbook sexual harassment and
I'm like if you felt that comfortable
saying that to mean there's no telling
what you're saying to other people who
looks at somebody like a complete
stranger you're 30 years older than me
you don't look back at a woman just tell
a I can look and tell by the way you
said you got some good who wants to hear
that when I was in school I was a
student so me my friend like went to
this school event so everyone got out
for just like a few casual drinks was
not drunk at all we're like okay we
should just be responsible he picked up
a ride normal friendly conversation with
this driver then me my friend noticed
something strange that the driver had
like a camera placed in the front of the
car and it was recording like we saw
like the red button flashing we're like
okay what's that for and I was expecting
him to just be like oh yeah I like to
record my rides like for like safety
reasons just to make sure like
anything happens like we'll have it on
records but no instead he was like oh
yeah yeah I record everything really my
personal use I just like to watch the
videos at home and we were immediately
freaked out and we were like okay sir
can you please stop recording us and he
started freaking out he started cursing
at us like calling us all sorts of names
okay we need to like get out he pulls
over on the side of the road and tells
us to get the [ __ ] out and we're like
what we're literally in the middle of a
highway and so we get out we don't know
what to do or who to call so we're like
okay I guess like let's call another one
and we ended up getting in a different
car and telling the new driver this
crazy story and he was like so
apologetic he was horrified that we had
to go through any of that luckily we
made it home safe but it was a very
uncomfortable situation little old me is
getting off of set and it's about 10
p.m. pull out my handy phone call myself
a ride I look down and it's like five
minutes away so I'm like okay I can deal
with this I'm watching as my driver
starts driving and just kind of circles
around the area the time had passed that
he was supposed to get here I call him
hey what's up where are you he's like
I'll be there in a minute okay cool a
minute passes and then another and
another and it's ten minutes later and
at this point I'm getting really nervous
I don't want the ride cancellation fee I
call him again
he picks up and he's like I'll be there
any minute I'll be there in a minute
he sounds kind of flustered he finally
shows up 45 minutes later he pulls up
and I can tell he's kind of pissed off
we start driving and every time we get
to a turn he asks me if we should turn
here
she probably followed the GPS we get to
the freeway and there's a row of toll
booths and when it registers in his mind
that he is gonna have to pay for one of
these toll booths and so we're driving
perpendicular to oncoming freeway
traffic as he makes this u-turn and I'm
holding on for dear life thinking oh my
god we're gonna get t-boned oh my god
this is how I go oh my god why didn't I
cancel this ride but we finally make it
downtown we're about to turn on to my
street and this voice just pops into my
head and says just tell him you're gonna
walk for the end and just get out of the
car and I don't listen he makes the
worst left turn onto my street and boom
we get rear-ended hit my head really
hard i black out come - and the police
come and an ambulance comes you know I'm
fine obviously but I couldn't move my
neck for like the next week if you have
a voice in your head that's like don't
go in this car don't go in the car funny
story is the set that I had been coming
off of I was playing a character who had
just gone in a car accident and hit her
head someone was obviously playing a
massive prank on me that day
[Music]